portland becomes the first city to ban
the use of facial recognition technology
by government agency and private
entities in public spaces
let me read this one more time portland
becomes the first city to ban the use of
facial
recognition technology by government
agencies and private entities
in public spaces mayor ted wheeler
said during hearings that portlanders
should never be in fear of having their
rights
of privacy be exploited by either their
government or by a private institution
freelance journalist kk
uh reported the ban also creates a legal
right for people to sue private
companies
that collect their information in
violation of the law and seek up to a
thousand dollars in damages
for each day of violation so portland
becomes the first city to ban the use of
facial recognition
adam what do you think about this you
know i don't know what to make of this
because
when i initially think of portland i
think a very liberal city
yeah right like oregon liberal
democrat um this
so on the surface i hear portland i'm
thinking liberal
then as i kind of unpack this a little
bit more i'm thinking this is more of a
libertarian like don't infringe on my
rights
and then i kind of gravitate to more of
like a conservative
you know you know let me do what i want
to do don't interfere
yes so i don't know what to make of the
story is this a liberal thing is this a
libertarian thing is this a conservative
thing stay out of my bedroom stay out of
my face say that am i right i don't know
what to make of this
but um they're standing their ground
either one way or another portland to
stand it up to facial recognition i
guess this 5g
is this part of that stuff or this is a
palantir what was that volunteer i don't
think volunteers linked to this
uh but uh facial recognition i mean you
gotta
why would a private entity i get
government because for police
law enforcement but why would a private
entity want
facial recognition is it for their own
security
well no i mean you've got to realize
this whole meeting that they're having
at the house with
you with the amazon google all these
guys is selling your data
of course right selling your data so uh
a a very
uh a big ted meeting that was that took
place 10 years ago
they said what is the best industry to
be part of to be a part of in the future
the next few decades
they said data it's all about data right
now whoever's got the most data
has the best access if you got data you
can
re-target target you can do a lot of
things if you have the data on people
right so
uh i understand why private agents like
why would private
enterprises want to have uh facial
recognition and government yes i get it
but
portland see here's here's the thing you
know how you sit down and you talk to
somebody
about politics like almost anybody i
talked about politics
and you say you don't ask them are you
democrat or republican you don't ask
them that
you just ask them basic questions you
say let me ask you
uh how comfortable are you sharing your
privacy with others people say what
okay how comfortable are you an
institution or an organization knowing
about your family you and your wife's
sex life
zero okay how comfortable are you about
the government or an institution knowing
exactly about all your financial
situation where you're absolutely zero
okay how comfortable are you a
organization knowing everything about
how you raise your kids how comfortable
are you okay business okay no i'm not
fair enough not zero
exactly let me let me ask you this let
me let me ask
you business let me ask you this how
comfortable
are you allowing strangers to break into
your car or your house without your
permission
of course not you're not comfortable
with that yeah are you comfortable with
that yeah no
okay okay how come if you were to choose
to live in another country
adam you got three kids you got four
kids what are one of the first things
you would consider before you want to
move into another country what would it
be what would that country need to offer
safety safety okay for your kids the
first amendment okay
first amendment okay let me ask you a
question if somebody comes into your
house and decides to take stuff
out should you have the right to hit him
upside the head with a baseball bat
yeah should you have the right if not
more but but i'm asking the simple
question i'm not asking politics
if somebody breaks into your house and
they want to steal all your you know
belongings
should you have the right to own a gun
and tell him to get the hell out of your
house
should you have the right to do that yes
or no sure okay so let's just say you're
upset about
somebody that is going against you in
politics
should you have the right to call a
meeting and bring your 50 friends and
family members to your place and say
look here's what we need to do go
go up against the mayor should you have
the right to have a meeting with 50
friends and relatives locally
okay so this everything i'm saying okay
so let's just say you go out there you
work your tail off you work 60 hours in
a week you miss
great memories of your kids and you have
to work that one weekend maybe even
you're working on christmas weekend
because
you are in retail you have to work on
christmas right
how much of your how much of your dollar
you make are you comfortable giving to
the government
the the very least is possible how much
is that very least what are you
comfortable without getting upset
without getting irate five percent five
percent
you make a buck i'm actually being
serious you make a buck what are you
what are you willing to give
what are you willing to get five cents
five cents what are you willing to give
adam
yeah i mean i want to pay his least
taxes give me the number what are you
willing to tell
so what's your question if i tell you
according to my tax bracket 39 something
percent no i didn't say what your
tax bracket is are you comfortable what
you're comfortable i'm not comfortable
paying [ __ ]
okay but watch this but say i come back
to you and i say okay fine you don't
want to pay [ __ ] you say no i don't i
don't want to pay [ __ ] okay
so is it fair to say that the roads are
on you right did you go to public
schools
i did so you pay for all publix your own
roads your own cops
so meaning you would like to pay some
taxes you say yes
what portion of your dollar that you
work your tail off would you like to
give to me
15 flat tax fine 15 are you being
sarcastic
no i'm not okay now that you're saying
look at this
the point the point i'm trying to make
to you is i agree with the people of
portland
yeah what the hell do you mean you want
to have facial recognition
you know first of all facial recognition
everywhere now
i don't want you to do any kind of
facial recognition to me are you a spa
are we going back to these
and just the fact that it says portland
becomes the first city to ban the use of
facial recognition here's a real
question who's really
how many people are listening to the
same so if they're the first city this
means all the
other cities are recognizing my facial
based on anywhere i go
what it's to me it's not even important
it's like you don't want to use your
face id anymore
and and by the way i know some people
are going to be like well pat you know
portland is this and portland is that
i've been to portland
believe me i know what portland's like i
had an office in portland in 2010.
i'd go to portland every other month i
had to go to portland in 2000. yeah
regularly
and it's it's definitely weird it's
qualified i've never been to portland
what's going on what's going on in the
northwest i've been very worried i've
never been to austin
have you ever been to austin austin is
weird that's what they're about austin's
got nothing on portland really
qualified weird wow qualified weird they
take you to whole different level
portland
but i get along with weird i don't have
a problem with the people i get along
with weird you get along with everyone
i get along with everybody but the point
i'm trying to make to you is how is the
weirdest city in america today
banning facial recognition
you